in recent years new research into
understanding how neural networks work
has really revolutionized our ability to
interpret how they operate providing the
tools and building blocks for explaining
why they make the predictions that they
do stay tuned as we dive into
convolutional neural networks and try to
understand how they see the world
welcome to AI adventures where we
explore the art science and tools of
machine learning my name is Yu Feng Guo
and on this episode we're going to see
how to use lucid to better understand
what neural networks are looking for
convolutional neural networks or CN NS
have significantly advanced the state of
the art of image recognition they've
achieved incredible accuracy across a
wide variety of tasks but understanding
what's happening between the inputs and
the outputs in those hidden layers
that's been slow going so today we'll
look at a number of different approaches
to try to gain some intuition behind
what it is that makes a CN n work
ranging from focusing on individual
neurons all the way to looking at the
response of an entire layer before we
dive in I wouldn't get us on the same
page about why it is that we care about
how a neural network arrives at the
prediction that it does isn't it enough
that the final prediction is right well
not quite in real-world production use
cases of machine learning image
recognition systems a lot of additional
value can be gained by understanding the
how and the why of a given prediction
this helps the end user of the
predictions better understand whether
it's being made for the right reasons
let's take a hypothetical example say in
medical imaging where small details can
really play a crucial role in
differentiating between different types
of results what if let's say a model not
only gave just the right prediction for
an image but it also provided
information about which parts of that
image were the primary contributors that
led to its
inclusions then a doctor could see
whether this model was coming to these
conclusions for the expected reasons
moreover this approach could even
potentially highlight new patterns which
hadn't yet been identified as useful in
these images so what kinds of tools and
approaches would we need in order to
construct this kind of understanding of
an image models predictions well let's
set the stage by first understanding the
structure of a convolutional neural
network convolutional neural networks
get their name from their many
convolutional layers and they work in
concert to understand the different
details of an image in the early layers
close to the inputs the convolutional
layers are expected to be looking for
your basic lines and simple shapes and
patterns further along in the network
the work from these early layers are
passed on words and respond to more
understandable looking inputs we might
see images that appear similar to
various parts of real-world animals or
objects this information then continues
propagating onwards through the network
and eventually reaches those final
layers which are put together in
generating the final outputs of the
network's conclusions these tends of
course look more directly like the
categories that we are expecting as the
outputs there are a number of parts that
make up any single convolutional layer
at the lowest level is the single
individual neuron neurons are the most
fundamental building blocks of a neural
network and the strengths of each
neurons response to input is what we
will use to understand their behavior so
now let's zoom out a bit and see how
multiple neurons can be connected in a
specific channel so a single channel is
made up of a two-dimensional rectangle
of neurons which are used to process the
previous layers
outputs there are many channels in a
layer each channel stacked on top of the
other much like a layer cake and within
a whole layer all the channels receive
the same values as inputs from the
previous layer but they each process
that input slightly differently looking
for different features all of these
outputs are then come
and pass onwards to the next layer now
that we have a basic understanding of
how a convolutional neural networks
layers are assembled let's take a look
at how to find out what a given neuron
or perhaps a group of neurons is
quote-unquote looking for when an image
is passed through the network in what is
called a forward pass each neuron
responds or activates to a different
degree now we can measure that
activation strength
well because it's literally just a
number that comes out the greater the
magnitude of that number the stronger
the activation now these activation
values can be positive or negative so we
can have a strong positive activation as
well as strong negative activations so
let's start by seeing what a specific
neuron in our network responds most
strongly to by looking at how it
activates when the network is presented
with an image input if we take this
train model and then hold all the
weights static so they can't change and
then we run an image through that
network and we measure what a particular
neurons activation value is we can begin
to optimize this input initially we'll
start with the image of pure static
noise and because neural networks are
differentiable we can figure out how to
adjust that input image that noise
there's just nothing there to get an
even higher activation value for that
specific neuron we're interested in so
we tweak that image a little bit and if
we're doing it right the activation of
the neuron will be even higher when we
pass that image through the second time
so then we can do it again
we can adjust the image to boost that
activation of the neurons response to
the image and pass it through over and
over again we repeat this process and
eventually you end up with an image that
has been optimized to activate one
particular neuron of the network
maximally the result is an image with a
focused region surrounded by a kind of a
more blended background now these
patterns can be all over the place and
thankfully lucid has made this really
easy to compute there's no need to write
an optimization loop yourself you can
just choose what layer channel and
neuron you're interested in
and we'll take care of the rest now if
we instead look to optimize the
activation of not one single neuron but
instead that entire channel of neurons
we can get a pattern that is a bit more
consistent and fills in the edges - and
this is what we'll be primarily seen
throughout the rest of our experiments
now let's take a look at some ways to
combine the different neurons together
allowing us to see how neurons activate
in pairs this is showing the optimized
input images when optimizing for two
different channels of neurons
simultaneously rather than just one what
ends up happening is that the images
sort of show up as a blend of the two
channels that they originated from and
finally let's see how we can interpolate
between two different neurons rather
than just copped amaizing for both
equally we can weigh them unevenly
giving us images that are along the
spectrum between the two channels this
gives us even more context about what
sorts of patterns these channels are
able to detect so far we've gotten some
background on CN NS and we've seen some
examples of feature activation at the
neuron and channel level in the next
episode of AI adventures we'll take
these ideas that feature of
visualization and apply them to the
entire image to create activation grids
and then we can use that to produce an
activation atlas which will give us
insight not to one neuron channel layer
or just an image but it'll allow us to
see how the entirety of the network
operates as one cohesive unit
if you want to learn more about feature
activations and to experiment with lucid
on your own check out this distilled pob
article really fantastic and try out the
lucid library on github thanks for
watching this episode of cloud AI
adventures and if you enjoyed it be sure
to hit that like button and subscribe so
you can get all the latest episodes
right when they come out for now go
check out lucid on github
[Music]
you